polizei großeinsatz beim ex us
präsidenten das fbi hat vor wenigen
stunden das anwesen von donald trump
durchsucht so etwas eine solche fbi
untersuchung durchsuchung bei einem
ehemaligen us präsidenten so etwas gab
es noch nie
razzia bei trump am abend um 18 uhr da
steht das fbi vordertür einsatzort
malabo florida das riesen anwesend von
donald trump die polizei sucht
geheimdokumente papiere aus dem weißen
haus die trump angeblich privat einfach
mit nach hause genommen haben soll das
fbi tramp doch einer ist nicht dann
trance selbst der ex präsident bestätigt
aus new york city den polizeieinsatz bei
ihm zu hause und er schimpft sein
anwesen befindet sich im
belagerungszustand
so etwas sei keinem anderen us
präsidenten jemals angetan worden trump
weiter diese unangekündigte
durchsuchungen meines hauses war weder
notwendig noch angemessen und auch trump
sohn eric schmidt im interview mit fox
news
sie haben ihn verleugnet sie haben ihn
herabgesetzt sie sind hinter ihm her
hinter uns allen es gibt in der
geschichte der usa keine familie der
öfter in den rücken geschossen wurde als
der tramp familie schauen sie sich den
generalstaatsanwalt bezirksstaatsanwalt
im ganzen land sie alle wollen donald
trump krankheit hat der us-präsident
geheime dokumente einfach aus dem weißen
haus mitgenommen es geht um diese
momente den abschied aus dem weißen haus
trump steigt in den hubschrauber mit
dabei ganze kisten akten geheimdokumente
geheime briefe auch von vorgänger obama
der us sender foxnews sagt nein das ist
rache rache an dem ex-präsidenten trump
anhänger wütend sie haben sich längst zu
hunderten auf den weg nach florida
gemacht bilder aus der nacht wie eine
bürgerwehr ziehen die tram fans in
malaga
und unserer us korrespondent herbert
bauernebel ist jetzt dort wo sich jump
selbst gerade aufhält in new york
herbert das erschüttert oder ja
zumindest südamerika heute auf ist das
eine notwendige polizeiuntersuchung oder
ist das alles wie fox news berichte wie
eric trump sagt alles politisch schikane
sogar eine art politische rache
dann muss man natürlich sehen welche
seite des politischen spektrums man
steht wenn man ein kritiker ist es
präsident ehemaligen präsidenten trump
wird man natürlich sagen ja das
geschieht ihm recht das ist absolut
gerechtfertigt ein fachmann kann privat
unterlagen aus der zeit des weißen
hauses nicht einfach mitnehmen seine
verteidiger die republikaner viele
seiner sehr loyalen anhänger sagen
natürlich das ist eine weitere aktion wo
eben die andere seite versucht einen
krieg gegen baumann tram zu führen um
ihm zu schaden besonders in einer zeit
wo er sich möglicherweise auf seine
nächste präsidentschaftskandidatur
vorbereiten könnte und welche dokumente
soll's da gehen wird irgend etwas
spezielles vermisst
das volumen wird beschrieben mit
ungefähr 15 kisten die eben hier in
malaga aufgetaucht sein sollen die
genauen inhalte sind unklar ist in
teilweise unterlagen papiere auf
möglicherweise kleine geschenke
tonträger andere dinge dass eben wird
jetzt versucht zu klären auch mit hilfe
des fbi jetzt denn offensichtlich haben
die fbi-agentin hier gesucht nachdem sie
gesucht haben und können jetzt
analysieren wie viel diese dokumente
jetzt wirklich in der privatresidenz vom
nordrand gelandet sind jetzt sind die
anhänger von dolmetschern wütend die
sind dort nach mar lago gezogen wir
haben gerade eric jump gesehen bei fox
news der ebenfalls wird oder alle sagen
hier will man jump schaden aber
gleichzeitig ja könnte all das kam
nutzen in einem bevorstehenden wahl kbw
ja offenbar auch sein profil als
märtyrer als politisch märtyrer schärfen
herbert
haben heute ein paar dinge schon mit der
in seiner opferrolle die ja oft gespielt
hat politisch gepunktet er verkauft sich
eben als der mann das volk ist er eben
gegen das system auf steht gegen das
mächtige system und hier auch deshalb
immer wieder in den beschuss gerät das
ist ein eindeutiger immer wieder spielt
und auf diese strategie setzt er
natürlich auch jetzt in dieser doch für
ihn auch schweren sturm und gleichzeitig
muss man sagen herbert wenn jemand
dachte nach der präsidentschaft von
donald trump diesen mann ist mann los
man weiß schon lange diesen mann wird
man irgendwie so schnell nicht los den
download charts
zu bieten und ihnen hier würde man hier
noch nie in den usa dank an unseren us
korrespondent herbert bauernebel nach
[Musik]